aujourd'hui j'ai une croix
18 heures étaient dans la rue sans eau
sans nourriture sans rien
nous a amenés au monde dans la cellule où nous nous sommes assis
seulement sur l'eau et sur le pain effrayant bien sûr
toutes les conditions nous étions environ quarante à travers
partager
nous avons dormi par terre, on nous a emmenés dehors pour
hall a gelé qui était malade malade qui d'autre
quelque chose bat très friands de gars
pour que 24h/24 et 7j/7 ne se contente pas d'être crié dessus
rue
conduit la moitié à la mort aspergé d'eau puis
avons-nous encore été retenus près de la stèle ?
la police anti-émeute est sortie et nous a demandé des passeports
Je n'avais pas de passeport, ils ont demandé un numéro de téléphone
ils ont vu tout ce que j'ai filmé au téléphone
quel type de 200 bus a commandé la police anti-émeute
ils ont dit
cette fille AvtoVAZ moi d'abord
attrapé l'un des miens puis j'ai commencé
résister alors il en a appelé un autre
le vent d'eux a commencé à me traîner, j'ai dit
que comment allez-vous regarder votre
mères à qui ils ont dit de fermer leur bouche
a donné un coup sur la tête et nous voici quand
la police anti-émeute est allée dire qu'elle était une prostituée
Shilov et m'a jeté dans AvtoVAZ
puis nous sommes tombés malades, ils nous ont dit
on s'en fout descends saute avec nous
de toute façon, c'est alors qu'ils nous ont amenés ici
cela ne veut pas dire mais j'ai demandé à appeler
on a dit à l'ambulance de fermer la porte alors vous
va-t-il roter du sang nous tous nous 17
heures passées dehors sur le sol en béton
divulgacher